le Tonquin la Nam et la Cochinchine ces
trois provinces ont été reliées à la fin
de la guerre et ont pris le nom de
Vietnam 60 ans après la défaite de Dien
bienfou l'Indochine est toujours dans la
tête du colonel àer de 45 à 54 il s'y
est rendu à trois reprises 2e classe
dans un régiment d'infanterie en 1945
pour la reconquête du Vietnam il
terminera la guerre en lieutenant
quasiment 10 années pendant lesquelles
il a vu la Mée vietmine se constituer je
parle dans 53 la montée en puissance du
vietmine était extraordinaire ils ont
été formés en Chine les unités ont été
structurées nous avions en face de nous
à di bienfou des divisions alors que
quand nous sommes arrivés en Cochinchine
il n'y avait que des bandes armées Dien
bienfou 7 mai
1954 la fin de plusieurs mois
d'affrontement sanglant dans la région
une bataille perdue d'avance pour
certains par manque de moyens une
bataille que n'a pas oublié le le
colonel àer voilà hiane 2 Eliane 4 le
montchauve et les les montagnes qui
dominit Dien bienfou où se tenaient les
divisions vietm si mai les viettes
étaient dans la plaine ils ont envahi
toute la plaine et ils sont arrivés au
poste de commandement les munitions
étaient rares les combattants étaient de
plus en plus rare nous avions beaucoup
de blessés et beaucoup de morts pour
Jacques h si Dine bienfou marque la fin
de la guerre d'Indochine c'est que la
France souhaitait l'arrêt des hostilités
pour le jeune lieutenant de l'époque
s'ensuit plus de 4 mois de captivité
marqué par les maladies par la mort par
de longues marches et par des corvés le
tout encadré par des commissaires
politiques ce qu'il voulait c'était nous
convertir au marxisme et il nous avait
fait comprendre que ceux qui seraient
fidèles au marxisme qui signerit les
manifeste seraiit libéré plus vite alors
évidemment ce chantage à March ch plus
ou moins sur certaines sur certains
camarades ou soldats qui étaient
vraiment fatigués et qui voulaient vivre
comme lui les autres attendront la
restitution des prisonniers à l'armée
française jacquesaler restera militaire
et se rendra plusieurs fois en Afrique
de l'Indochine il n'en gardera selon ses
mots que le meilleur le courage la
gentillesse de sa population et la
richesse de sa culture depuis sa
retraite pleine et entière il s'est
consacré à l'étude de l'Indochine pour
comprendre pourquoi il y avait
marcher